this is a production of Cornell
University
so waste not want not
which is a great saying of course and as
you appreciate with many spraying
applications there's quite a lot of
waste as I'll show you
and so I've was particularly asked to
talk about recent advances in technology
particularly then towards precision
farming as you realize there's the great
movement in the world towards the
precise application of all inputs into
farming and certain cases the outputs
and so I'd like to share with you the
work that we've done here at Cornell I'd
like to acknowledge the help of the of
my three most recent postdocs Jordi
Lorentz and Tomas pelea are both from
Spain and have now gone back and have
good jobs in Spain and Cheung Yuen with
was from China is now currently working
here in the US at another university my
group at Cornell are charged with
looking at pesticide application
technology as a way of improving
spraying via engineering methods we do
this in three distinct areas tests new
sprayers new spraying ideas develop
methods for our growers
I've worked particularly with fruits and
vegetable growers the fruit growers in
particular as you'll see use a machine
that blow spray all over the place so we
have a lot of waste hence the title of
this talk and so we develop ways of
improving deposition and reducing drift
and finally because I have a 60%
extension position we do a lot of
extension demonstrations both here in
the US and around the world I've just
come back from Australia and Europe
where I've been speaking the grape
growers and I leave again on Monday to
talk to a Vacarro growers in Mexico and
as I've never yet seen an avocado tree I
think Monday is gonna be a very steep
learning curve and the two days of
touring around see the trees but a
spread to many people a sprayer is a
sprayer as a sprayer that as you'll see
is not
true but in all cases no matter which
audience I'm speaking to our challenge
is to produce quality food and drink for
the consumer off of a livestock that
we're about to feed in the case of a
consumer then disease disease and insect
free and blemish free of course the
challenge to the farmer or grower is to
improve the spray deposition throughout
the canopy and when I work with fruit
crops you will appreciate for example in
citrus that's quite a challenge when you
look at citrus trees primarily in New
York State of course it's apples and
grapes apple apple trees and grapevines
and it still remains a challenge to
improve deposition throughout the canopy
and a lot of our work has been done on
that nurse I'll show you and reducing
drift is the other big issue society
doesn't care for drift
we don't want drift in our waterways our
water supply and of course where we have
all these wineries here in the Finger
Lakes on Long Island etc it's this type
of thing which affects the public
profile of agriculture in the world and
the public's perception of what we're
doing and this this photo is from the
Hudson Valley from a vineyard and you
can see this tractor it should be green
this one here is from a place fairly
close to here and again that should be
green people who pay by John Deere pay a
lot of money for that green paint and
the cover it here in died Thane and here
in surround is a very poor image to give
to the buying customer coming to your
winery or your fruit stand so I'd like
to split my talking to two main areas
one is the work that we've done up at
Geneva and the second is examples of
boom sprayer work that other people have
done spraying is simple everybody will
tell you that you just get a sprayer out
the barn full of water and product your
pesticide put it in and off you go well
I've made a 40-year career trying to
complicate what is a simple process
and as you'll see we've developed it
into the volumes of air and liquids so
their tooth in fruit spring there are
two distinct categories two fluids air
and liquid and so in the last seven or
eight years we've concentrated with the
three postdocs I mentioned on trying to
measure the airflow monitor the airflow
in one way or another and then adjust
the airflow equally changing the amount
of liquid that's being applied this is
the classic spray account this work was
created by Santiago planners over in
Catalonia in near Barcelona in the
townland layer they layer the University
and has stood the test of time you see
it's very old piece of work hasn't
changed in New York in particular well
the whole of the US we use sprayers like
this to spray trees apple trees and
grapevines probably in the world
probably 95% sprayers still like this
the fruits and you can clearly see or
whatever application rate you can read
as well as I can so I tend not to you
can see on the slide but you can clearly
see that at the very low application
rates 10 gallons per acre then you use a
very very fine nozzle which leads to a
lot of drift and so when we're looking
at the red symbols only 54% is going in
the canopy 45% is drifting away and if
ever you go around the vineyard or the
orchard in the spring you will see this
when there's very little leaf to
intercept the spray but a little canopy
there's a tremendous man adrift and at
best and say this work has stood lots
and lots of other people have tried a
repeated the Santiago plan a cease work
and this stood the test of time at best
we were only getting 75% in the canopy
this any one is appalling it's a waste
of product it's bad for the environment
from the farmers point of view is
economic you know economically
just crass the ability to be wasting so
much money and so it begs the question
is this the best we can do is this
precision spraying the other thing
that's happened orchards if you love
familiar with the modern system we have
more trees per acre we're looking made
anywhere between seven hundred and two
and a half thousand trees per acre huge
hedge hedge like structures very close
together ten eleven feet apart between
the rows and the trees now are very well
manicured just like vineyard compared to
the photo on the right which as you can
see is the traditional orchard and the
growers still use the same air sprayers
based on 1960s technology and so as I'm
one of the only people working in this
area in the US then there's quite a good
challenge and of course a very good
access to research dollars as you will
see so I have very little competition in
this field here so our dream has been
for the last decade to create a fully
automatic sprayer and that's the the
basis to my my talk we first of all look
at our target whatever that might be
is it the leaf is it the disease is it
the fruit it's an insect whatever it is
in relation to the growing canopy like
all plants early season versus late
season full canopy we do this with an
array of sensors which I'll show you
we've tried different types we put it
through a processing machine and then we
adjust the two fluids the liquid flow
and the air flow because in fruits
canopies we need year to help penetrate
these dense canopies so the controller
is the smart box in the middle obviously
and that's what my postdocs have been
extremely good at creating the software
and as I say the sensors recognize the
canopy and then we make adjustments on
the move GPS then everyone knows about
GPS you have on your
on car roadmaps stuff like that these
days so I won't dwell on that but it
does give us our location so this is old
hat as you know GPS and it gives us
exactly where we are what we've done the
Geneva we fitted an array of sensors on
a sprayer this is a vineyard or who
variety of in yeol French hybrid and you
can see as the tractor goes through the
row then the senses of sending out a
sound wave so we're using ultrasound of
the Sonics to send out a sound wave
notice the envelope is the white
envelope is wider than the row of grapes
we also do the same in Orchard's here's
the modern orchard system very narrow
canopy and manicured canopy just like
the grapes and a wider envelope than the
actual canopy width okay
so we're using sound as you know as you
know sound can be generated by using a
magnet in a coral so we can allow
speaker
it's example we're all familiar with and
we hear this sound a sound wave we can
record sound by sending it back to a
pickup to a microphone as you can see
all the effect the loudspeaker and as
the magnet moves back it now sends us a
signal here is the trace from a typical
sound wave over time so we have a signal
in voltage and the time frame in seconds
we're using ultrasonics ultrasound then
is that a higher frequency can you see
two megahertz between 20 kilohertz and 2
Meg is the Sound area or area of the
sound wave that we're picking up okay it
works simply by sending out a sound wave
and then it receives the echo and the
highest voltage signal we receive is our
peak so when we set up our equipment we
set it against a wall this is a solid
you know for density of canopy as our
interest then the wall is a solid so
that's
100% dense as you appreciate and so our
Soundwave gives us this voltage in our
machine and then anything less than that
it would loves to be a less dense or a
sparser canopy this is the system we use
you'll see in a moment here it is as the
tractor goes down the rows I showed you
in the video we're measuring the sound
waves coming back depending where it is
within the canopy we're getting
different peaks according to the density
of the canopy and so when we total that
the peaks together we get a little
certain value that value is represented
in volts okay in 2014 we have a look at
this and thought this well earlier than
that we started to work within the first
published results were based on the 2014
season and you can see here we have the
date 21st of May right through till the
19th of August notice then every week we
go to the orchard or the vineyard and
measure the canopy and we were looking
for what we estimated as density and we
call the IDI estimated density in those
days we would look at both sides of the
canopy left and right or east and west
and then the dotted line is the average
and so the first thing we notice then as
the density change as the canopy got
heavier into the season progressed
therefore we were getting a different
signal voltage again so this was really
really good but like all good research
at the end of July due to the vagaries
of the New York weather we got a
hailstorm came through a severe
hailstorm and that was here and it only
came to the Experiment Station but
Geneva didn't hit any of our neighboring
farms and it decimated everybody's feel
class all my colleagues with Apple
everybody all the grapes have just hit
by hit big hailstones and all the fruit
went with parish as parish did just went
no good so that's the date of the
hailstorm
yeah end of July we then went to the
field back ten days later we were also
devastated by this and we noticed that
our signal was lower because all the
leaves were shredded so our density had
changed and so there you you can see it
in the orchard in the vineyard they then
wanted to save what little fruit was
left and so they net the canopy net the
vines which is in the shaded area and
because they then gather the vine leaves
together our density signal went back up
so we thought this is jolly interesting
but we hadn't compared it with real
density measurements that our colleagues
in horticulture use so we asked
colleagues like Alan Lac so how do you
actually measure density as a as a
horticulturalist and they use a system
called p QA and p QA involves thrusting
a pole into the canopy and you can't
everytime the pole or stick bamboo cane
in this case every time the bamboo cane
touches a leaf or touches the fruit and
you get a number and as engineers we
wanted to repeat this performance so we
created a small frame every week one of
our Cornell Summer Scholars went out
throughout the whole of the growing
season and put in the stick with the pqa
here it and would count the number of
leaves this you know it's a very simple
system and was developed by a man called
Richard smart who was a grad student
here and has gone on to become very
famous viticulturist anyway it's an
acceptable practice it was acceptable
enough to get it published so pretty
good so we're quite happy and so you can
see as the season went by as the leaves
filled our pqa went up equally
look at our signal in voltage from our
sensors so this
great grapevine Cabernet Franc from
you're familiar with it and so you can
see that when we lay the one against the
other pqa against voltage what a
wonderful graph what a wonderful end to
a great career you might say that we've
finally got something as good as that
and we did the same with apple trees and
we've done with a number of different
varieties of grapes and the number of
varieties of apples because this project
in particular was funded by apple and
grape industry what can we do though
from a spraying point of view we now
know there's a signal a voltage from the
sensors from the ultrasound sensor
giving us a number how do we then relate
that to the spray how do we make
real-time changes as we're driving along
so remember there are two fluids the
liquid and the air in both cases we have
demonstrations to show you how we can
change liquid using a little of aerial
select nozzle or a capstan nozzle and
the air flow by a system we've patented
here at Cornell to adjust them the air
flow or using Australian's fan system
called Saudi fans so we'll start off
with liquid the first system we looked
into was the use of pulse width
technology pwt those of you who are
familiar with a bubble jet ink printer
which I know many students aren't old
hat really bubble jetting printers but
the idea was to have a small valve which
went up and down rapidly and would fire
dots of ink at your paper and create the
letter or the font whatever the same
principle was developed into a spray
nozzle by other researchers and
depending it's it's simply a little
valve really like a solenoid valve so
you apply current to the valve and the
valve will get lifted and so in this
case the valve is up here when the valve
is lifted the liquid can flow out
through the nozzle if you have a long
current
you get a longer lift and therefore more
spray goes out if you only open the
valve for a short time you get a very
small amount going out and as I'll show
you in the next video this gives us a
pulsing effect to the spray nozzle and
so some of you will remember years ago
there was a specialty crop research
initiative it still goes on and the
federal government gave boatloads of
money to some of us and we teamed up
with Carnegie Mellon that the robotics
Institute University of Florida because
we were working with citrus and at the
Cornell we developed the sprayer part to
go along with this device and so let's
have a look at that and this was to
develop an autonomous fully autonomous
tractor and sprayer and there it is is a
classic air blast sprayer and you'll be
able to see the tractor will move
through the orange grove completely
without anyone driving it it's fully
autonomous and it will change the amount
of spray according to the size of the
citrus tree see no one's driving it in
in Florida they have a thing called
greening disease that's spread by a
psyllid which is little insect spreads
it's devastating their industry and so
they were particularly interested in
this because they have replant trees a
little tree that maybe three feet tall
very sparse and then a very very dense
machine so that we're monitoring the
canopy we're monitoring the canopy and
then creating a map of the different
sized trees the algorithm then changes
the signal that goes to the pulse-width
nozzles can you see them pulsing all the
time and then see here a small trees
you'll see every now and then tiny trees
and then these very dense orange trees
if there's a gap it switches off there's
some little fries they might only want a
teaspoon full of spray and a small
amount of air whereas this will 1/3 buck
Falls a spray and a lot of a to blast
the spray okay and so there it is we had
this huge gone nearly 5 million dollars
so everyone was quite happy so we did
that the problem is it's too
sophisticated for most growers you know
it's very nice system it's you know a
lot of brainpower into it but it's too
risky so in New York not that our
growers are not sophisticated anything
but but we wanted to develop a simpler
system so here's a sprayer that was
given to us by a company here's the the
tall mast with the ultrasonic sensors on
it this is the worst photo you've seen
ignore all these wires now that I draw
an attention to them you look at them
whether they should and so here it is
it's a tower sprayer and attached to the
system is an air compressor and electric
valves and what we're going to do is use
air to open or close these valves let's
have a look at this here we are what
we've chosen is a Leffler which is a
german nozzle assembly the Leffler
varial select so instead of having a
little pulse with nozzles pulsing
wearing themselves out this is a
standard nozzle that all growers were
familiar with or are familiar with and
now we have a nest of them three of them
in a small cluster and so by opening or
closing an individual nozzle or any
combination of nozzles we can get a
different flow rate and so here we have
the different pressures that they might
operate that if we open just an orange
nozzle we'd get a flow rate of about
nine liters a minute as you can see
there if we open the green nozzle we get
about 11 or 12 litres a minute and then
if we operate the yellow we will get
about 16 litres a minute so by having a
cluster of three nozzles we get a
variation in flow rate but
look if we have combination orange and
green orange and yellow so on and so
forth
green and yellow and then all three of
them on so you can see by having this
system which is very simple it's just
operated in our case by air can also be
operated electrically and so we can go
from about nine liters per minute all
the way up to 38 liters just by
switching on different nozzles as I'll
show you and at different pressures so
you can change pressure and therefore
you get there let me just show you this
at work and we'll come come back to the
graph here are the nozzles this is a
sensor this is in our lab as the sensor
moves towards the blackboard which is
representing the canopy so the closer we
get to the canopy then the different
nozzles switch on and off you see there
we see the gain in the mode you see the
switching around so we can change the
rate when we wait to the field this is
what the farmer does traditionally in
the red line where they use a standard
rate let's say 75 gallons per acre
sensors the blue line this is what they
are suggesting our flow rate should be
and then the dotted line is what the
actual sprayer nozzles put out because
we're using flow meter to measure the
flow so for the longest part until we
get here we are pretty much a good fit
to what the sensor seeing what the
output is showing it's all based on
Arduino boards those of you are into
electronics will know that the simplest
way to make a prototype is with these
$10 circuit boards that you can make
this huge Internet
discussion groups chat rooms about how
to operate these things so we can take
all these things flow rate pressure
there are the sensors put it all through
this device and then logged with the
data logger which tells us what the
signals are seeing and then using a
simple onboard computer send it
wirelessly to the laptop at the end of
the row and we know what's going on here
you can see it again
close up can you see them going around
and then they're operated by electric
valves or two opening or closing air
compressed air lines the green is the
compressed air line so we're switching
on and off as and when we need to change
the liquid flow but what about the air
because this is the other other fluid
involved so this is the the system we've
got a patent on here at Cornell and you
can see it's a simple louver we call it
the Cornell louver system it slides and
in fact it's not just simply sliding
it's actually redirecting the air
turning it 90 degrees so if any excess
air the air is not required therefore
its success its turn 90 degrees and
comes out the back of the machine
whereas the green is where the spray is
leaving the sprayer and so early season
minimum air flow very sparse tree
maximum at the end of season then we
want more air to penetrate the canopy
and so we can adjust it we adjust it
then by using a using an actuator here
it is an electronic actuator here then
is the sensor when he moves them the
washing up Bowl nearer the sensor so you
see the actuator changes so if density
of the canopy the signal changes so it's
the echo is collected and so the
actuator changes so that was that again
it's the Arduino board system same
system as we've just seen so it's very
simple to repeat
and so that was okay and our work shows
when we look at deposition which is how
do we know that we've got enough spray
on the lead you can see by changing the
air flow we're getting very good
deposition at lower air speeds in fact
as good as a high speed and the high
speed air creates a drift which we don't
want and therefore we're having same
deposition at much lower air speeds
which cost less money the modern farmer
though those that have seeing to the
future they don't really want these
old-fashioned air blast sprayer so
there's quite a development towards
these Saudi fans we've done trials up in
Orleans County with this type of sprayer
this grower has four of them and you can
see they're vertical fans and this is
what the machine is seeing there's our
estimated density signal in in blue left
and right hand side the tree and then
this is the fan regulation and you can
see the fan can react very rapidly this
is on the Variety pinata and you can see
tremendous response there's a gap in the
in the row of trees there's some trees
missing and you'll see that when we
watch the video and so we can regulate
the fan speed yeah it is
so here you can see how narrow the
modern planting is of a modern orchard
and when the machine starts it's on full
bore
so it's blowing the spray right through
you see it's going to land on the grass
it will result in pollution and then the
sensors kick in and it'll start to keep
that spray just within the canopy it's
not you see it's just your wisp where
there's a gap in the canopy so it's
still working we'll move in a wee bit
can you see so it's still just puffing
in it's not blowing it all the way
through and this is with a modern
sprayer with the old-fashioned spray
will be all over the place so it's
certainly controlling air flow here's
the gap in the trees
and they then picks it up so that's
changing air and liquid flow
then I'll just skip this part if I may
because of time and show you the boom
sprayer section because that will
interest no neither there anyway there
it is so boom sprayer is what
developments have occurred there you can
clearly see the first thing is boom
movement when the big sprayers go across
the field either very rough fuel or too
fast we're going to get boom movement
either boom bounce or boom you're where
the Boone's move backwards and forwards
why aw boom the or and so that's a big
problem when you get boom you're you get
acceleration of the boom
the tip of the boom moves forward
rapidly and then it lingers and then it
swings back and you can see you've got
400% application and then where as it's
moving it's moving through the
horizontal plane and you get less
application so you're getting
ineffective application even with a boom
spread this is work done by Vander
Xander at Varga ningún and you can
clearly see that when deposition is okay
we get lower infections when deposition
is not a satisfactory we get these peaks
in infection here okay so as the green
is down then the disease has gone up you
can see this shown in three-dimensional
model where we've got these Peaks
depending on this sprayer boom what can
be done about it
we can buy boom levelers here's one
attached to the boom and this is in the
US here and again it's ultrasonics so
it's sending the sound wave down it hits
the wheat crop or barley whatever our
target crop is and then it stabilizes
the boom so it will adjust the boom up
and down hydraulically else you've seen
this we showed you the Leffler system
where we have a cluster of three nozzles
in this case we have a cluster of four
nozzles on the horizontal boom and again
we can change the flow rate so we can
change work rate due to variation in
speed we can vary the application range
for a specific area of crop and we can
switch from low to low drift nozzles if
we need the boundary of a field near a
water course and you can see clearly how
are the four nozzles switch in and out
and so depending on what you want where
you can flick from the cab a switch to
change different colored nozzles okay
and then you could have all four on but
that's so that was the early days that
would say a decade ago now we've got GPS
originally giving us boom sections as
you know the boom is in one to three
sections on the left three on the right
and one in the middle so 7 section boom
and we could switch them on and off to
prevent overlap on the headland those of
you know the farming terms the headland
ran the boundary the edge of the field
we've now moved on again where we can
not just the boom sections the
individual nozzles and this is work done
by Scott Shearer who was at University
of Kentucky and there's now there ha the
Ohio State University and he is showing
six in this case 6.2 percent reduction
in sprays but he recorded up to nine
percent reduction so just simple
technology will allow you to save nine
percent your spray because you can
switch on and off you know where you
turn on the headland all done through
GPS and switching the valves off equally
changes in pressure affect them as you
know pressure affects nozzle output and
so this is some work they did in
Kentucky at Lexington to show the
changing pressure across a field with
changing your pressure comes changing in
output and you can see if the nozzle is
fluctuating from as low as 20 psi you're
only getting point three of a gallon
permit
if you go all the way up to a hundred
then we're at point eight gallons so any
variation as he found in this field then
he's going to give us an incorrect
application rate so maybe the product
won't work anymore and then the final
part to show you what is the most modern
thing one their big silver medal in the
Agrotech now to show in europe and that
is a Curie working to zero one of the
Bane's of the farmers life is going back
to refill because if the effects output
because you have to transport the
vehicle it's not in work and so this
system allows you to see what your flow
rate has been how much is was in the
tank to begin with how much is left and
so if our last point if we originally
wanted to put on a hundred liters per
hectare so ten gallons per acre and the
Machine says we can actually use if we
use ninety one because a hectare 9.1
gallons a hectare we will run until we
get to the end of a rope so you're not
going to stop down in the middle of the
field and so it predicts when you need
to refill the sprayer based on flow rate
location with GPS and then tank contents
and so you start the system and it flags
up that if you reset it to automatically
to 91 rather than a hundred you will get
to the end of your work zone so it saves
a lot of time in the amount of liquid
left in the sprayer and when you refill
so you change what you want is your
default and so that's the latest system
and I'd like to leave you with this
slide and that is in field crops we have
tremendous adoption of technology in the
Midwest states they have auto steer they
have all these things have to show or
some of the things I've just shown you
on the Amazon sprayer but in
horticultural crops which is my area we
have a fear of technology and I show
this to the growers all the time their
biggest point is the cost involved in
repair
because they like they're what we call
nut buggers you know they like to spend
their time trying to mend the sprayer or
mend them tractor and after so many
hours they have to give up throw their
arms in the air so what we fail to do
that and then still have to pay seven 75
dollars an hour to get it fixed so it's
a different mindset but the more we show
them other aspects of Agriculture then
hopefully they'll they'll adopt this
technology but at the moment it's still
very early days to get them to switch if
you're excited by spraying I commend
these two excellent publications to you
where you'll see lots of our research
work great thank you very much this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu